JILLIAN: Linden Schaffer
is a wellness travel
expert and consultant.
Early on in her fashion career,
she realized the way she worked
was turning her into a
tightly wound ball of stress
and tension, which I'm sure
many of us can relate to.
So before every
business trip, she
conducted hours of research
planning her own self-care
in her few precious
hours of downtime.
And it changed her life.
Today, Linden leads
travelers around the world
on wellness vacations via
Pravassa, the first wellness
travel company.
Linden has been recognized
as a leader in her field
and as a winner of the
prestigious British Airways
Face of Opportunity contest.
She contributes to columns
in the "Huffington Post"
and "mindbodygreen," where she
writes about wellness, travel,
and lifestyle.
She is a regular
speaker at conferences,
including the "New York
Times" and "Los Angeles Times"
travel shows.
Her first book, "Living Well on
the Road, Health and Wellness
for Every Traveler," became
a number one best seller
upon release.
And here's Linden.
[APPLAUSE]
LINDEN SCHAFFER: Good afternoon.
Thank you, Jillian, so
much for hosting me.
Thanks to Google.
Thank you guys for spending
your lunch time with me.
I'm really excited to be
here today and talk to you
about living well on the
road, or what I also call,
how to plan a business trip
that doesn't kill you--
very important in the day
and age that we work in.
So who am I?
And why am I here to talk
to you about this today?
I am the girl who,
at 16 years old,
had my first international
travel experience.
And it's something
that stuck with me.
I was able to go to Australia.
And ever since
then, my wanderlust
and my idea of wanting
to explore the world
was deeply seeded
and rooted in me.
I spent 15 years in the fashion
industry in New York City.
And my time there, I would
go in for my job interviews.
And we'd have this
great interview.
We'd talk about what
I was doing or about
to do with this company.
And at the end, the
interviewer would say, hey,
do you have any questions?
And I would say yes.
How much is this a
work travel situation?
And how much vacation
time do I get?
So you can imagine, these
interviewers were like,
wait a second.
Your biggest concern
about this job
is how much time you get
to spend out of the office?
OK, let's think about
this a little bit.
So luckily enough,
throughout the career
that I had in the
fashion industry,
I was able to travel a lot.
I would travel domestically.
I would travel internationally.
I would travel for weeks on
end with no break in between.
And there I was one
morning, waking up
in a hotel room in Italy and
having no idea where I was.
So I'm sure that's
happened to some of you
in this room before.
You had no idea
between the jet lag,
between where you were
yesterday, where you're
going tomorrow, where are you?
And I said, you know what?
I got to-- something
here has got to give.
Something's got to change.
I can't be stressed out.
I can't be burnt out.
I can't be productive
in this situation.
So what is it that I can do
to change the way that I'm
living while I travel?
So what I did was I started
to just simply pool from tools
that I had used in my own life.
So whether it was yoga
practicing or meditation
or eating healthy
at home, I figured
there's got to be a way
that I can implement this
while I'm on the road as well.
So I started doing my own
little tips and tricks.
And I would take
that circuit again.
I would see the same people that
I was always traveling with.
And they would look at me.
And they would say,
you know what, Linden?
You seem rested.
You seem happy.
You seem healthy.
What has changed?
And how do I get that?
So I started to think
to myself, OK, there
must be something here.
Everybody is stressed out,
burnt out, living on the road
when they travel for business.
And they need to get
some sanity back.
They need to get some
semblance of themselves back.
And this led organically
to the launch of Pravassa,
which is the wellness
travel company I run.
It was the first wellness
travel company that
was created here in the US.
And throughout that
time, the clients
that I would take on the road
for these health and wellness
vacations wanted
more information.
How do I implement
this when I get home?
Traveling with you is fantastic.
But now I need to figure
out how to put this
into my own lifestyle, which is
how "Living Well on the Road"
came to be.
It's the book you guys are
all getting a copy of today.
That goes into
health and wellness,
the science behind it,
why these things work,
which is what we're going
to talk through a little bit
today.
So one of the things I
think we can all agree on
is that travel is stressful.
There is no way around that.
And the first thing
that we have to do
is recognize that
and say to ourselves,
why is travel stressful?
Because as humans,
we are hardwired
to avoid negative experiences.
We've all had a bad
travel experience.
We've missed the flight.
We've run for a flight.
We've had an altercation
maybe with the gate
agent who wouldn't get us on
that flight, whatever it is,
right?
So those are the
experiences we internalize
and the experiences
that we remember.
And so we start to
make our decisions
from this fear-based place
of I don't want to do that.
I don't want to do that.
So let's talk a little
bit about that fear base
and what it is
that it does to us.
And then let's learn some
tools of how to deal with that
and move on.
So when we're talking
about the stress of travel,
the stress of travel affects
our whole mind/body connection--
the physical, the mental,
and the emotional.
When it comes to
our physical selves,
you can picture
yourself now, right?
You're running
through the airport.
You're trying to
make that flight.
You're the last
person on the plane.
There's no room
for your luggage.
So you're trying to cram it in.
You're trying to cram
yourself into the seat, right?
All of these things are
completely stressful
and take our body out of whack.
We're disrupting sleep patterns
when we change time zones,
even especially if we're doing
it for a short period of time.
We're increasing our
sedentary behavior.
You know, you guys
here at Google
are lucky enough to have
these great outdoor spaces
and these conference rooms so
you can get up and move around
a little bit.
That's not the typical workplace
environment these days.
So people are taking
themselves from sitting
behind a desk to sitting on a
plane for hours on end, right?
This is stressing
our physical system.
When it comes to
our mental system,
we're also taxing our brains.
We live in this day and
age, because we're so
connected all the time
with everything that we do,
we live in a constant state of
chronic stress on some level.
We have moved away from being
in that nice relaxed place
to being in that place
where we're constantly
in our fight or flight mode.
So add on top of that
business travel, right?
You have to make sure
you're working very well.
But then you also have
to make sure, like, oh,
how am I going to pack?
Am I prepping for my
meetings properly?
And then the anxiety
and the worry
that's added on
top of that when it
comes to all of these
things, so our brain starts
to work over time.
And our emotional state, we
have anxiety around travel.
There is a lot going
on in the world today.
Whether it's where
we're traveling,
whether it's going through
the airport itself,
we start to get anxious.
Am I going to make that flight?
Have I prepped for that
meeting really well?
Am I going to have an issue
when I land on the ground?
There's also a lot of
mistrust these days
in the travel industry.
I'm sure we've all seen
the viral videos that
have come out in
the last few weeks,
even specifically, right?
So the clients and
everyone who is traveling
has an inherent mistrust
of these companies
that we are entrusting
our business travel to.
And then fear-- so back
to this making decisions
from a place of fear.
Some people are
afraid of flying.
So that itself sets you
up in a negative space
before you've even taken off.
So these are all
things that we have
to deal with when
it comes to travel.
So why do we do it, right?
Why do companies
keep sending us out?
What is the benefit
of business travel?
And there are many benefits
to business travel.
The biggest things
here are it builds
relationships and retention.
And that is not only from
the client and employer side,
but also from the employee
to the employer side.
So when you're able
to get on the road
and you meet your
clients face to face,
it builds these relationships.
It builds these relationships
between you and your client.
You bond with your client
when you're in front of them.
And it endears
you a bit to them.
You build this
personal relationship.
Also on the other spectrum
of that, employees
who like to travel
or who travel a lot
and have found ways
through these tips
that we're going to
walk through to make
it a little bit of a leisure
and enjoyable experience
at the same time, you will
stick with your company longer.
So that's great for
the company as well.
It increases productivity.
When you have
face-to-face meetings
and you're able to
sit-in front of somebody
and talk through problems,
talk through solutions,
it increases the
project productivity.
I'm sure all of you, maybe
today, maybe tomorrow,
will be on a
conference call, right?
So we thought, oh, when
conferencing gets big,
when video
we're not going to need that
face-to-face meeting anymore.
And actually, that
hasn't proved to be true.
We are more productive
when we have
our person-to-person,
face-to meetings.
So when you're on
a conference call--
I'm sure many of
you have done it--
the statistics are that 60%
of people on a conference call
are also doing something
else at the same time.
So they're not really paying
attention to what's going on.
And some of that's
because maybe you're
on this big call with
all these people.
And you're not needed
at that moment.
So you're checking your email.
You're figuring out what your
dinner plans are going to be,
whatever it is.
And other statistics that have
come out around the conference
call, right?
And I will tell you
right now, I have never
been one of these
people, that over 50%
have admitted that while
on a conference call,
they've been in the bathroom.
So I'm hoping that they
were on mute, right?
Because nobody
wants to hear that.
[LAUGHS] But these
are the things
that when you have face-to-face
meetings, they don't happen.
You don't get distracted.
Getting up, moving, getting out
of your typical environment,
whether it's a
cubicle or an office,
promotes out-of-the-box
thinking and creativity.
It puts you in real
life situations
where you're taught
to think on your feet.
And you're taught
to be flexible.
So these are all
things that companies,
in terms of why they want
you to business travel,
makes it productive
and beneficial
for them as well
as for yourself.
The statistics around the
spending for business travel
are huge.
The global business
travel spend in 2015
was $1.2 trillion dollars.
And it's rising every year.
And it's also
something that actually
rises during a recession
because companies
have found that back to
these first three things
that we talked about,
relationships and retention,
productivity and creativity,
are things that keep clients
around longer.
So even in a
downturn, people are
spending on business travel.
And why is this?
Because of what is invested,
the return is very high.
So every dollar that's
invested, that a company invests
in sending you on the road,
they see an increase of $9.50
in their revenue
and $2.90 in profit.
So that's why you're getting
sent on the road all the time.
So how is travel changing?
Business travel has completely
shifted in the last 10 years.
32% of millennials who
are doing business travel
and have some control
over their schedule
themselves are booking
directly on their phone.
They're researching and
booking on their phone, which
has created this great
world for all of the apps
and all the ways that
are coming out now
that support business travel.
Nontraditional
booking platforms are
becoming more acceptable
in traditional companies.
So the shared economy of
things like Airbnb, Lyft, Uber,
they're creating
business divisions that
are partnering with
corporations and allowing
you to stay like this.
What's really interesting
in terms of accommodations
and in terms of blurring
this line between business
and leisure, for 56%
of people who book
on an Airbnb-type platform
for your accommodations
on average book five-night
trips, whereas when
you're solely looking
at hotels, you're
booking three-night trips.
So you can see, when it comes
to this idea of figuring out
how business travel
is working for you,
this is something interesting
that comes into play as
far as that's concerned.
Everything is ending
up on social media.
This is a huge change that's
really exploded in the last two
or three years.
And you can find this
stuff on any platform.
It's not specific
to one or the other.
So here's the thing about
business travel and people
posting about it
on social media.
They post the good.
They post the bad,
which we all know.
But companies are also
interacting with their clients
when it comes to social media.
And it's really become
an acceptable way
to get real time feedback.
So I can give you an example.
A few years ago, my husband
and I were in Columbia.
And I was there on business.
And we came at different times.
And so we had
separate flights out.
He was booked on
a JetBlue flight.
And there was only one flight
a day and three flights a week
that were departing where
we were in Columbia.
And he missed his flight
for whatever reason, right?
So there is nothing he could do.
He couldn't get on another
flight with JetBlue.
He had to figure
stuff out himself.
But what he did
immediately was he tweeted
JetBlue about his problem.
And they responded right away,
apologizing and giving him
a travel credit for everything
that he went through.
So this goes back to, how is the
industry changing both the way
that we use it and the
way that the companies are
interacting with their clients?
The biggest change
in the last few years
when it comes to business
travel deals with perception.
And this perception is
both how the employer
views business travel
and the employee as well.
So businesses see people who are
willing to travel for business
as more valuable employees.
And that goes back to that
productivity, creativity idea
that we were talking about.
It sparks new ideas.
It sparks partnerships.
It sparks more loyalty when
you're working face-to-face
with other people.
What's really
interesting this day
and age when it
comes to travel, 30%
of people who are
interviewing for new jobs
have said that they are
willing to take a pay
cut or a lateral move if it
means they're able to travel
for business more.
So think about that, right?
It is becoming more acceptable
to be out of the office.
It's becoming more acceptable
to work in different ways.
And employers are
recognizing these benefits
and figuring out
how they can tie
that back to their companies
being more profitable.
So now that you know that
it's time to travel, right--
we know what the benefits
are for the companies.
And we know what the
detriments are to ourselves.
How do we change
those detriments
into positives for
ourselves when we travel?
How do we counteract
those physical, mental,
and emotional tolls
that are created
and so that we can function
optimally when we're traveling?
So what you need to do
is you need to create
some tools for yourself.
So what I want to do here
today, a little experiment
to see how it works for you.
We're going to do a
breathing exercise.
So I want you to take
anything that's on your lap
and shift it off.
I want you to scoot
forward in your chair
so that you can feel
your feet on the ground.
I want you to sit up straight,
rest your hands in your lap
so you feel comfortable.
And then I want you to trust me.
And I want you to
close your eyes.
So take a second here just
to check in with yourself,
to take a pause.
And I want you to breathe
in, take a deep breath in.
And I want you to release
it out your mouth.
So breathe in and
release your breath.
[DEEP BREATH] Breathe
in through your nose
and release it out
through your mouth.
[DEEP BREATH]
So now that you're centered
and you're feeling yourself
in the room right
now, I want you
to repeat in your
mind on your in-breath
the words I am and on
your out-breath, here.
So breathe in, I am.
Breathe out, here.
Breathe in, I am.
So do it a few more
times on your own.
And now open your eyes.
So hopefully that few seconds
of breathing that I just
taught you is the
first tool that you
can sort of put in your
business travel tool box.
So what just happened?
We removed some of your
external stimulation.
By closing your eyes and
by being in this room
where it's quiet, we
took away the visual
and the audiosensory
loads that we all
have these days, where
we're technically
overloaded on all that.
Being able to take way outside
input and outside sensory,
it allows us to shift our
subconscious thinking.
It brings us into
the here and now.
By focusing your
mind on your breath,
by focusing your mind on
that I am here statement,
you're bringing yourself
into the present moment.
You're not thinking about
something that just happened.
what's coming up this afternoon.
You're making yourself present.
And all of this helps trigger
a relaxation response.
So the idea by removing this
sensory input, by going inside,
even if it's just
for a breath or two
and focusing on yourself,
you're restricting
the flow of cortisol, which
is our stress hormone.
And it's constantly producing.
So if we can find a way to
reshift, not only our thinking,
but reshift the way the
chemistry is in our brain,
and we're taking ourselves
out of that survival mode,
out of that fight or flight
mode and into the present,
we can learn to relax.
So some people may have
felt anxiety or discomfort
while we did that,
which is totally fine.
This is how I felt the
first time I did it, too.
I couldn't focus.
My mind was everywhere.
This was something that was
totally new and different
to me.
And I was like, how
am I supposed to relax
when I'm doing this, right?
It takes practice.
And that is just, you have
to put something into it
to get something
great out of it.
And the reason this is, is
because what we just did
affects the prefrontal
cortex of our brain.
We have all these
neurotransmitters in there.
And they start
firing on high speed
when we're doing something
new and different and
uncomfortable.
And immediately, our brain
says to us, warning, danger.
Don't do that.
Don't go there.
So it takes some time for
us to retrain ourselves.
It takes some time
for us to stabilize
these neurotransmitters
in our brain
and create these
new pathways that
will lead us to relaxation.
So what's great about that
exercise, that first tool
that you now have
in your toolbox,
you can do it anywhere.
You can do it when
you're stuck in traffic.
You can do it when you're in an
Uber on the way to the airport.
You can do it when you're
sitting at the airport
and your flight was delayed.
And there's nothing
you can do about it.
You can do it when you get
on the airplane, right?
So this is the first thing that
you can do to set yourself up
to have a positive
experience, to set yourself up
to change the
narrative and change
the story that you tell
yourself, that business
travel is stressful.
So let's flip it around.
Let's reorder the way
that our brain is firing.
And let's say to ourselves,
we can start this
from a relaxed and
positive place.
So let's get to some
practicalities here.
What are you packing
when it comes
time for your business trip?
I have some props in
the back of the room
that you can take a
look at on your way out.
I prepack.
I have a section of stuff in my
house in a drawer in my closet
that has all the
things that I know
through developing my travel
routine that are prepacked.
And it's one less thing I
have to stress and worry
about when it comes time to
get ready for a business trip.
For me, I focus
on five areas that
are going to affect my health
and wellness when I travel--
how I sleep, how I eat, how
I move, how to stay healthy,
and how am I going to work?
And so there's easy things that
don't take up a lot of room
that you can keep prepacked,
even in your suitcase
if you want.
So then you don't even have to
remember what drawer you put it
in, right?
We want to take all
these choices and all
of these decisions away and
make it easy for ourselves.
We want to set ourselves up.
We want to take out that stress
and make it into success,
so traveling with things
like earplugs or eye masks
for the plane.
I pack nutrient-rich snacks.
I have-- whether it's
almond butter or something
like this that is going to
keep me healthy and happy.
And that way, if
I get somewhere--
we were just talking
before I came up on stage
about how you land somewhere.
And it's too late
to have dinner.
And you end up
reaching for crap.
Well, when you have stuff
packed with you that you know
is healthy and good
for you, then great.
There is no decision there.
You've cut all of that out.
When it comes to movement, if
you can pack workout clothes.
If that's too much for
you, take a jump rope.
Take one of those
Thera-bands that you've seen.
You can use props that
don't take up a lot of room
to keep yourself moving.
And even if it's for 10
minutes, right, you can move.
Get up and move on the plane.
Or you can use these props when
you get to your hotel room.
Staying healthy is a big one.
When we're changing
all these environments,
we're meeting all
these new people,
we're shaking hands,
things like that,
aside from washing
your hands, what
can you do to stay
healthy when you travel?
Drink a lot of water, more water
than you would normally drink.
I would say reach for
that as the first thing.
Things like coffee and
alcohol dehydrate you.
So if you're going to be heavy
on the coffee and the alcohol,
think about that
and purposely drink
more water to counteract
those effects as well.
I travel with these
amazing wipes that
are these essential oil wipes.
They smell like
lavender, which is great.
Because they smell good.
And lavender is relaxing.
And it also has
anti-bacterial properties.
So the first thing
I do when I get
onto a plane or
the first thing I
do when I get into a hotel room
is I break open those wipes.
And I wipe everything
down to make sure
that I am cleaning
it for whatever
was there before me, right?
There is a woman that I saw
on the plane coming here,
out to LA actually,
who had this awesome--
I hadn't seen it before.
It was sort of like a
fitted bedsheet that
was made for her plane seat.
So she pulled that whole thing
out and just covered it up.
So there's things
that are coming out
into the marketplace that
make it easy for you.
So you keep these things packed.
When it comes to work,
chargers, adapters, USB cords,
business cards, these are
things that we probably
have two or three of, right?
So take a pile of that and
put it in your suitcase.
Put it in your pre-travel pack.
And you take out that stress
as far as that's concerned.
What about your
pre-travel routine?
So this is something that's
going to take you a little
while to cultivate
and develop because it
is going to be specific to
what you like and how you live.
It took me a long time
to cultivate my routine.
It's a 24-hour
routine of self-care.
And I extend it.
I extend it to 48 hours if
I'm going away for a long time
or if I'm going really far.
And for me, this is what
has set me up for success.
This-- by sticking to this
routine, if you land and you
have meetings or if you
land and you immediately
have to go to a business
dinner or a conference
or whatever it is,
you already know
that you're starting off from
a place of health and wellness.
So what this means
for me-- oftentimes,
I'll take red-eye flights.
So my 24-hour self-care
routine starts by the way
that I sleep the
night before I leave.
So for me, that's seven to
eight hours of quality sleep.
And the first thing that I do
when I wake up the next morning
is work out.
And that workout can be anything
that is good for you, anything
that you like to do.
I try all these different crazy
workout routines to experiment
and see what I like.
This is one of my favorites,
doing some aerial work here.
Hanging upside down gets
all of your lymphatic system
moving, your organs moving.
So it doesn't have to be a
traditional workout routine.
Get yourself moving.
Because you know you're
setting yourself up
to be on a plane
for a little while.
You can move through
this whole routine
and use this as a
guideline for yourself.
I drink my veggies.
I want to make sure I'm getting
all the vitamins and minerals
and nutrients that I need.
And I'm not sure what I'm
going to eat when I land.
So I sort of
pre-game it that way,
right, making sure I get
all the things that I need.
I move throughout the day.
So I'll have walking meetings
if I'm meeting people somewhere.
I will get up and I
will walk and get lunch
instead of eating it at my desk.
I will consume extra water.
I always have a portable water
bottle with me wherever I go.
You can fill it
up in the airport
as well before you even get
on the plane, which is great.
I have what I call a
nutrient-rich last meal.
So I don't eat on the plane.
I fast on the plane.
And I'm going to talk
about that in a second.
So in order to set
myself up to do that,
I need to make sure that
that last meal that I'm
eating before I fly for 16
hours, let's say to Asia,
is something like salmon and
quinoa or farro with spinach.
So I want to make sure I'm
getting these healthy fats.
I. Want to make sure that I'm
getting something with protein,
again, something that's nutrient
rich that will keep me full
and keep me healthy
before I get on the plane
so I'm not tempted to reach for
M&M's or something like this.
I pack snacks, which
we talked about,
which are great for if you
get hungry on the plane
or when you land if it's
something that you need.
And then I also
plan my plane time.
A lot of people, you'll say,
like, oh, I hate flying.
Because it's this dead
time for me, right?
Flip that story in your mind.
What can you do with
those hours of travel?
For me, I love to not be online.
I know you can pay
for Wi-Fi these days.
But I'm like, forget it.
I'm connected all
the rest of my life.
The time on the plane is
for me to do things my way.
So whether that for me
is writing in my journal,
whether it's
watching a movie I've
been wanting to
see, whether it's
trying to get some extra
sleep, whatever it is.
It could be work.
That's fine.
But plan your time so you
can use it effectively.
And again, it's all
about setting yourself up
for success.
So how are you
healthy on the go?
We've talked about what you
need to have packed and waiting.
We talked about your
pre-travel routine
that you need to
set up for yourself
that's going to work for you.
So now that you're ready,
now that you're in the air
and on your way, how
do you stay healthy?
So technology--
you gotta love it.
Because people are coming up
with all these amazing ways
to stay happy and
healthy when you travel.
These are three categories
that I look at a lot
when it comes to the
technology that I have
on my phones and my tablets.
So food, hotel, and
wellness are big areas.
There are some great
food apps out there,
one called Grab So if you
do a lot of domestic travel,
download this to your phone.
And what it is, is it
gives you, in major cities
around the world,
their airport menu
layout for all of
the restaurants
that are in the airport.
So you can search through.
You already know what's
going to be in the terminal.
You already know where it is.
Bonus, you can
pre-order your food.
So this way, there's
no waiting in line.
There's no wasting time figuring
it out, where you want to eat,
what you want to
eat, is it healthy?
So it's a great app
that does that for you.
Happy Cow, if you've
ever heard of it,
is a vegan vegetarian app
that's actually worldwide
and recommends restaurants
around the world.
Hotel apps, Dayuse is
one of my favorites.
So there is this trend that
started a few years ago where
hotels realized, look, we
had these empty rooms, right?
Even if we're 90%
occupancy, which
is a great number
for a hotel, there
are still a number of rooms
at each hotel every day
that go unused.
They've decided to target
to the business traveler.
So this Dayuse app lets you rent
a hotel room for a few hours,
which is awesome.
Because what can
happen is, let's say
you're in town for a day.
And you arrive early.
But you don't have a
meeting till late at night.
You can pay for-- find a great
hotel for a few hours using
this app.
And you can shower.
You can have a nap.
What's even better,
you get access
to the amenities of the hotel.
So the first thing I do
is head to the steam room
or the sauna, right?
That is a treat.
And that is something that is
going to reset and refresh you,
especially after
being on an airplane.
And it's a good
use of your time,
where you're not necessarily
sitting in an airport lounge.
So check that out.
That's a great piece
of travel technology.
And of course, there's
new wellness apps
that come out every day.
Headspace, if you've heard
of it, it's a meditation app.
Headspace is actually partnered
with some airlines out there.
So you can have this
access to this app in plane
as well on the screen
in front of you.
And Train is a great
sleep cycle app
that was developed with
the University of Michigan.
And it helps you sort
of retrain yourself
when you're trying
to get over jet lag.
And so on the plane,
this is the big thing.
So you have all these apps.
You have these
ways to set you up.
You're ready when you land.
But on the plane
itself, especially when
you're on the plane
for this long time,
how do you optimize your
health and wellness?
The first thing is really easy.
You just want to smile
at everybody when you're
going through the airport.
We talked about how
detrimental travel can be.
And most travelers out there
are operating from that space,
right?
So it takes a simple smile
to make somebody's day.
It also endears you to the
staff of the airplane, right?
You're angling for that upgrade.
You're angling for whatever
it is, that extra blanket.
Smile at everybody.
There's no harm in it.
It only sets you up to
be in a happy place.
We talked about wiping it
down, the wipes or the seat
cover that will
keep you healthy.
This is the big one--
skipping the food and beverage
that's offered on the plane.
And I know some
people, like, OK,
the food in business class
and first class is the best.
Why would I skip that?
I have to tell you that both
Gordon Ramsay and Anthony
Bourdain have sworn that they
will never, ever, ever eat
airplane food.
So that should
tell you something.
They understand the food
process, number one.
So they know what that
whole back end looks like.
And they won't touch it.
In general, what happens
scientifically when we travel,
the airplane pressure in the
cabin plays with our taste buds
and with our texture.
And so to counteract
that, the airlines
have had to develop food
products that taste good.
So how did they do that?
They pick high
calorie, high fat,
high sugar items that will
counteract the dampening
of our taste and our texture.
So the bottom line is,
whatever kind of food
that they're feeding
you, it's not healthy.
So it's healthier to not eat.
Or it's healthier to bring
your own snacks on the plane.
When it comes to beverages, we
talked about alcohol and coffee
and how they dehydrate you.
Your atmosphere in that plane,
in that air cabin pressure,
dehydrates you.
So you're just
adding to the mix.
You're compounding
that dehydration
when you drink alcohol
and coffee on the plane.
The other thing that I
should warn you about
is they don't wash those
coffee pots very often.
So think about
that the next time
that you want to have
coffee on the plane.
Maybe that will deter you.
And you'd rather wait till
you land and pick it up
with your Grab app instead so
it's waiting there for you.
And then return to that
breath exercise we just did.
Return to that I am here.
You can just
breathe if you want.
But use this as a
time to kind of tune
out everything around you
and tune into yourself.
The number one
travel hack that I
can recommend if you don't have
it already is Global Entry.
Does everybody here
have Global Entry?
Yes.
No.
Yeah.
OK.
You want to get it.
It's $100, the best
$100 I've ever spent.
And what it does is it
gives you TSA pre-check
so you don't have
to wait in line when
you get to the airport.
You don't have to
take your shoes off.
take your laptop out.
You get through the
line really quickly.
And then on the back end
from international travel,
when you come home,
I have timed my entry
into the country from
the moment I step off
the plane to the moment that
I am at the curb outside is
eight minutes on average.
Granted, I only take
a carry-on, right?
But eight minutes, right--
I have just skipped a
whole lot of stress.
So whether I'm coming
back from business
and I want to go home
and get some sleep
or whether I'm coming
back from vacation,
you hold on to that
more zen vibe, right,
when you're not immediately
assaulted with these things.
So Global Entry,
highly recommend it
if you don't have it already.
So all of these things that
we've been talking about,
all of these tools, we're
using to increase our success.
We're taking those
detriments we talked
about in the beginning, those
lugging around suitcases, those
worrying about your flight,
worrying about what you packed,
worrying if jet lag is
going to affect you.
And we're finding new
ways to allow ourselves
to optimally function, to
enjoy this travel experience
a little bit more by putting
a little effort into it
at the time.
You'll find more tips
on this in the book.
But you have to really
dive into and find out
for yourself sort of what
the pressure points are
and what makes you
not enjoy travel
or what makes it hard to travel
and change that narrative.
Change the way that you
think about those things
that you do for yourself.
So now you're ready to
rock your trip, right?
You're all set up.
You have a great
pre-travel routine.
You've figured out how to
stay healthy on the plane.
So how do you make
the most of your trip?
Because you know when you
leave, some of your time
is going to be spent on work.
Some of it will be
personal time, especially,
again we're extending our
stays to add personal time
into our vacations in some way.
So how do you take advantage
of all your surroundings
when you're doing this?
When it comes to work, these
are the three main things
that eat up our time when
we're business traveling.
We're in these face-to-face
meetings which we talked about
because of that retention and
creativity that it sparks.
We're dealing with our email.
And we're in events, so
whether that's conferences,
whether that's team
dinners, whatever it is.
So how do we change how
we approach these meetings
so that it works for everybody?
One idea is just to get out of
the office setting if you can.
So I don't know if
you've heard of this,
but there is this
phenomenon that's
been sweeping some companies
called sweat sessions.
Has anyone ever had a sweat
session with their client?
Do you even know what that is?
It's taking your meeting
out of the office
and taking it into a
healthy environment.
So meet your client--
have you had this relationship
with your client for a while?
You know they love Pilates.
You know they love spin class.
You know they love to--
they have a favorite
healthy breakfast spot.
Change your meeting there.
Change your meeting to
a different environment.
And you'll notice how,
again, it will bond you
to your client a little more.
You've got more to talk about,
more outside of the office.
And it sparks that
creative thinking as well.
When it comes to email, if
you have the opportunity where
you are when you travel
more of a digital nomad,
set yourself up
for the opportunity
to focus on email
at segmented times.
So what I can do,
especially here in LA,
right, we don't have
the beach in New York.
That's where I want to be.
So I will set aside an hour,
let's say in the morning
or in the afternoon.
I will go to the beach.
I will take whatever
device I need.
And that will be my email time.
And I can get
everything banged out
in that hour in an
awesome environment.
I see something more than the
four walls of my hotel room,
which can really be a drag.
And it grounds me to
the space where I am.
And it changes.
It makes me happier.
It makes me happier to
get out of the indoors.
We spend 80% of our time inside.
So if we can do a few
things to shift that and get
us outdoors more or get us into
a different environment more,
then go for it.
When it comes to events
and entertaining,
see if there's a way that
you can sort of control
some of this.
I can tell you that
in the last few years
of my job in the
fashion industry,
I would probably spend
five times a year in Vegas.
And when we were there, we were
required to entertain clients
every night.
So we'd have this full
day of working, full day
of standing up on my feet.
And then I was expected
to entertain at night,
which is totally fine.
But what I said to my boss
at one point is like, look.
If I'm required to do this,
then I want to plan it.
I want to be in charge of
how this goes down, right?
So luckily, there's
great options
in Vegas and in most
places in the world
if you do a little
bit of research.
I was able to find restaurants
that had healthier foods.
I was able to find
restaurants that really
cared about their ingredient.
And it offered me
something as well as
it offered the client something.
So you can have that
control over it.
If you're in a conference,
talk to the conference planner
and say, you know what?
I know you usually
serve lunch meats.
But maybe we can get
something different this time.
Maybe we can get something
healthy this time.
You are very lucky that
the company that you
work at right now has
been a leader in this
and really cares about the
employees and their health.
And so they go out of
their way to provide
some of these options.
But that's not always the case.
So we're working when
we're business traveling.
But we also have personal time.
We also have downtime.
So that's something that
is really important for you
to remember.
Just because you're
on a business trip
doesn't mean that
company owns you 24/7.
You have to find a way to,
just like you would at home,
disconnect and do something
for yourself every day.
So it's up to you.
Figure out where you can control
your areas of your business
trip.
Is it your schedule?
Are you able to push
meetings later in the day?
Is that when you work best?
Does that give you time to
use one of these hotel rooms
for a few hours and refresh?
Are you able to
control your food
or your fitness or your sleep?
Or how you recover--
are you able to plan on both
ends to extend your trip
so you make it more
interesting for yourself,
you make it more of
a discovery option.
And then your
environment, right?
We talked about seeing the
four walls of your hotel room.
I have to tell you, I
have a pretty good job.
This is what my
environment tends
to look like when I travel.
If anyone wants to join
me, I would love it.
But because of this, I am able
to choose how I set myself up
when it comes to working, right?
So that first picture, whether
it's outside of a pool in Bali
where I'm overlooking
the ocean, I
can sit there for the
afternoon and do my email.
I can book a room that
has my own private pool,
like this place in India
where I am able to, again,
at the end of every day, take
five minutes to be in nature,
to be by myself in nature.
Or in this other
option here, doing
yoga first thing every
morning when I was in Vietnam.
It's a good way for
me to start my day.
And there's hotels
out there that are
offering all of these options.
Same with healthy food, right--
there are so many choices these
days if you know where to look.
It does take a little
bit of research.
But once you find the
places that you like,
especially if these are areas
that you travel all the time,
these are great resources
for you to just have.
I started this
conversation telling you
that I was in a
hotel room in Italy,
and I had no idea where I was.
Well, what's the first
thing that I started
doing for the next few
days after that trip,
is I would get up a
half an hour earlier.
And I would completely
ignore the breakfast that
was at my hotel with my team.
And I would go out.
And I would walk the streets.
And I would find a
local place to have
my cappuccino in the morning.
Because that set
me up, like, OK.
I'm here.
I'm in Italy.
I feel like I'm participating.
And it made me happy, right?
And that's the key.
You're going to work better.
And you're going to work
smarter when you set yourself
up in ways that work
for you and your body.
So we've gone through
the whole trip.
And it's time to come home.
What is it about business
travel or travel?
How can you create
these routines?
How can you live
well on the road
so that you can work smarter
and yield better results for you
in your personal life
and for the business
that you're taking care of?
So it's important
that you create
these pre-travel routines.
It's important that you
work them and stick to them.
They're going to change
throughout your time
that you're using them.
And that's OK.
And what you need
to do is once you
find things that work for you,
you need to condition yourself.
And you need to condition those
around you for your return.
So what does that mean exactly?
Do you know, like, OK.
I'm going to take a red eye.
And maybe your company
offers comp time.
So you worked on a weekend.
You're taking a red eye.
You're landing Monday morning.
Are you expected to be
in the office right away?
If not, see if you can give
yourself a day to recover.
Or if you are expected
to be in the office,
maybe you can plan
your week out.
And you push all your
meetings till Wednesday.
So you give yourself
time to recover.
You give yourself
a little break.
And it sets others up for
how they interact with you.
What I love to do and I've
learned throughout the years
is my out-of-office
notification.
So what I do is I place my
out-of-office notification
to go live a day before I leave
and not to end until a day
after I come home.
And what's nice about
that is, again, it's
setting up others that I
might not be available.
Of course, I have the
option to turn it off early
or go back to work early.
But What this does is
it creates boundaries.
And it creates expectations
for those around you
and sort of trains them on what
you found to work for you when
it comes to business travel.
So thank you guys.
It was a pleasure to be here.
And I hope you learned
a little something
that you can take with
you on your next trip.
I'm thrilled that you're going
to get a copy of the book.
And I hope that you can find
more tips and tricks in there
that will help you travel.
And I mentioned to you,
I do run Pravassa, which
is a wellness travel company.
And I'm thrilled to say that we
are actually part of the Google
Perks program.
So if there is
ever an opportunity
that you guys want to take
a vacation, whether a group
setting or private
setting, because we're
part of the Google
Perks program,
there are some added
discounts in there as well.
So hopefully I can see
you guys on the road.
We do have a little
set-up for Q&A
if anyone has any questions
that they want to ask.
I'm happy to answer them.
If not, that's OK.
Any questions?
No, OK, cool.
All right, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
It was lovely to be here.
[APPLAUSE]